welcome everyone to Tuesday evening
class so I choose this game to show you
my game actually from last year's st.
Louis Spring Classic played here at
chess club against a very strong and
talented player
Jeffrey Zhang so Jeffrey is one of that
you know up-and-coming top GM's
and he's rating at that time was 2652
slightly slightly hard maybe me okay I
was 26 61 so about same rating so I'm
black in this game d 4 is 6
why do you think I play the movie 6 who
can tell me why I'm playing the movie 6
what am i offering Jeffrey to go to
Caleb aha
so if you place a 4 now we transpose
into which opening the French defence so
he could play this we've had a game
before that was a French defense but he
said no let's play just a d4 Knight f6
g3 so which line which opening is the
entering into here do you know what is
the name of this opening here he's
entering into nil Catalan ok Catalan he
wants to put the bishop on g2 and you
know try to have this fianchettoed
Bishop put pressure on this long
diagonal cut a long pressure I was
expecting that Bishop before check if
they should beat you this was a
preparation that tournament was a very
successful tournament for me I won that
tournament clear 1st place and kind of
was getting a little bit lucky in my
preparation whatever I prepare I could
get on the board so when that happens
that's a sign of you gonna have you're
gonna have a good tournament if you
prepare things and you and those things
that you looked before the game appear
on the board so not always that happens
so actually pretty rarely that you have
so many but this was also a preparation
but he was well prepared as well okay
the main move here is just to drop a
bishop back only seven and try to claim
that the bishop is misplaced on the kill
but that's a theoretical discussion
there
so let's I just took and play d5 Bishop
g2 c6 idea behind c6 it's just you know
to protect my d5 pawn and also try to
shut down the bishop on g2 now he plays
Knight f3 Knight bt7 developing castle
castle so now he played a very
interesting move 95 which he was a
little surprised because according to
the rules did white finish his
development no right now that means this
is it the right time to attack will try
to do any aggressive things no right
because you have to usually complete
your development before you try to do
any attacking ideas right complete
development before you start attacking
so but nowadays with this computers and
everything it's very hard because
computer throws an idea out there and go
ahead try to figure out over the board
what to do so this was a sort of a
novelty idea that he did I I was
familiar with the moves like rook c1
here even sometimes Knight a 3 but I
wasn't too sure about this move 95 so
what do you think I should do here what
is the best way to respond against 95
was the best way to respond against it
that's what I played excellent another
move was Knight takes e5 but I knew that
he would have very long analysis in this
because obviously when he played the
move Knight e5 the first move that you
analyze in your preparation is Knight
takes e5 and then we enter into this
long discussion of this move or this
move follow it up with f6 but it seems
like white maybe holds it's very slim
very very slim advantage in those lines
so mine was actually very concrete I'm
asking him what are you planning to do
with your knight are you gonna take my
knight then I just capture back with a
Bishop f4 as expected he is playing
quite aggressive Geoffrey you know he
likes to with white he likes to have
initiative so this was no surprise that
he will play this move what should I do
now what's the drawback drawback the
with the weakness weaknesses of his
position now do you see anything any
weaknesses something we can do about it
I was thinking about that but it felt
like things will start to open up and
you know a rule comes in on c5 x-raying
the Queen I wasn't so sure if I'm quite
ready for this yet think they're a bit
you know give yourself a little bit of
time
look the eight I played 94 he was also
consideration but look at this move rook
da developing the rook into the game at
some point x-raying the Queen and it's
not so easy for him either it's a useful
move nightie-night a3 played by my
opponent he wants to defend the c4
this way and also he wants to put a rock
on c1 and basically claim that my pieces
are now misplaced that's what he's
trying to do 90 for activating my knight
and putting pressure on the Queen if he
takes I plan to take back with the pawn
yes questioned on e4 I could play f5 and
protected ya if needed if needed
yeah I mean if you take he didn't take
by the way yes I take so what's queen is
little bit our country
Wow at the right time b6p should be
seven maybe comes in two so let's say
Queenie tree right I think we got it we
got a game here it's that's a bit a bit
of a messy huh it's a bit of a mess I'm
not sure but it feels like it could go
either way because he kind of opened up
his King and if I get the right moment I
can maybe organize an attack but he has
a strong 925 definitely
okay well he went here
and now he just wants to take it twice
he just takes it twice and
I have a nice position so no choice I
have to strengthen the position and then
next move I would like to eliminate this
strong night he played III kind of
strengthening the position when opponent
Knight is in the middle of the board and
you have a knight that can eliminate him
it's less active what you supposed to do
without thinking usually take it
absolutely the knight is very strong
here so and if you leave that night you
always have to watch out that night
jumping around attacking the Queen
attacking the Queen side king side so
you eliminate powerful Knight by
capturing it he takes back now my queen
is a little bit misplaced you agree it's
you know if it takes I don't want to
take back this way then it's passed so I
need a good square I need a good square
I need a good square for good square for
my queen which square seems to be the
logical one Caleb absolutely seven
moving it away from the C file and now I
have some ideas jump here if needed some
potential jumps here perfect it is here
now okay this is another moment now I
need to develop my bishop I have two
ways to do it here could you name the
both well the one it's very easy you see
it probably but what's the second idea I
have two options in this position you
know in this kind of structures you
don't want to play see if I they'll open
up the position too much yes
b5 or b6 the beef I can't I just take
take 95 because I have a night here
right I can just capture it capture
capture night X Neil yeah so two options
I have Bishop d7 Bishop e8 which I did
in the game or b6
I like which p6 more active okay CA
something like that I would prefer so
every should be seven actually I think
b6 would have been a little bit more
active b6 would have been a little bit
more active with idea Bishop a6 hello so
yeah but I think I later on a little bit
regret it playing the Bishop d7 I
thought yeah well I won but yes but then
I was my be sure was a little bit
passive I feel like b6 I like if I had
this position again against against you
know next time against anybody I want to
go be six which basics which was more
active here on a6 a lot more potential
just at that time I wasn't so sure about
playing b6 because if it takes the C
file opens up you know and this is also
normal idea so both ideas are playable
but later on I discovered that when I
was playing the game that Bishop was a
little bit passive so but on a6 it would
be a little bit more active so I think
we should decide which is fine it's a
solid move
Bishop e8 so he said might be one but
now as you can see it takes him a long
time he played 93 now he goes back to
b12 just to try to trade my night he
should be a normal night see three fish
page five three moves got my Bishop to a
decent square what I like about this
Bishop maneuver I kept my structure
intact you know they were so protected
when you make a move like b6 you a
little bit loosening up your pawn
structure this way structure is very
solid so that's why I preferred this
idea computer actually like the b6 setup
a little bit better because he he has
little bit of pressure on here he takes
so how should I capture back any other
suggestions do we want to give opponent
a protected pass pawn no right so of
course we care about and plus now we
have the C file for the rook maybe he
takes it takes so we arrived the
following structure here so I have this
pawns similar to his pants and what do
you think of this position what is the
first impression it's blocked
well quite his MO actually so it's white
to play what is the first impression
here do you think it's equal or white is
a little bit better white is a little
bit better okay tell us a reason what
reasons well this rook f1 idea I'm not
too worried about that file to be honest
what I'm worried about the C file
actually this is what I'm more worried
about because if he enters to c7 then
his rook is gonna be true
seventh-ranked continuously attacking
that is my main concern
yes know if it was my movie would be
easier a little bit it's his move
Caleb your evaluation what do you think
of this very slightly better
alright that's that's I think that's
what the computers basically stands yeah
very slightly better might be five where
is the night going ah you're gonna
capture this well at the moment Queen c7
will be met by rook d7 so that's first
things first okay well I'm not sure okay
I go I pass I'll make a pass
okay so he's entering here entering here
96 now worried about this expose king
he's not worried about the expose King
all right all right let's see look at
that Bishop now it's like an anchor on
f3 yeah
how you cannot remove that Bishop Queen
a 400 what are you planning to do don't
see the threat yet let's go let me
continue my plan now I want to go h4
weaken the position and then Queen g5
the knight on d6 actually if you think
about it right it it looks very nice
right the night here very nice but it's
sort of away from the king so if things
get dangerous here this is nice this
guy's not gonna make it to the defense
and I'm gonna line up my ruse on that
file
I might just abandon the Queen side give
up all this pawn say 7b7
in order to do a checkmate with Queen
g5h for ideas Roxy - Caleb continues he
believes in the position let's see wait
[Laughter]
that's it
well we have Roxy okay just discovery
check with a bishop hope bishops are
generally better than night you know
that right
that's why they worked a little bit more
their former and right in end game
especially bishops they're a little bit
stronger and this is an example we see
here both pieces look nice but the
bishop is just more powerful in general
when the game starts you gotta be
careful giving up your bishops you
cannot just give up your bishops for no
reason you know I see that happen all
the time people just make a move it just
give up the bishop bishops a little bit
more in my opinion please three and a
quarter I would give three in a quarter
at least okay some positions Knights are
more dominant
especially when it's close positions but
you have a lot more positions in my
experience that the bishops are actually
stronger than the night especially in
the end games when there are pawns on
both sides of the board if you have
pants on both sides bishops are stronger
if you have pawn on one side of the
board then which piece is stronger
usually Knight right because he can jump
around from the light to the dark scores
also it's your bishops are very
effective when you have a passed pawn
and Knights are not very effective
against the passed pawns usually I mean
they can try to block but then they will
be very passive so back to the game
Caleb this plan didn't quite succeeded
because and you know the funny thing is
it's about to be made and I don't even
see a threat yet okay don't see a threat
yet
alright back to the game so now I think
he made the right decision takes takes
Bishop h3 by Geoffrey activating the
bishop putting pressure on his six he's
controlling the C file it's a little bit
of a problem
so what should I do he's got the F file
he's got the C file he's got the bishop
putting pressure on me it's not looking
that great for a moment how do you
improve your pieces
what did like a tent okay first things
first let me shut down the look and I
kind of like this bishop there it's like
it's a nice bishop it's like threatening
something you know it's always good to
have pieces on active squares you know
if you go here if you go here I think
we're just basically shaking hands you
know I think I mean I think everything
will come off let's say you go here I
take take take take and
I think
I think that might be the outcome - uh I
don't think I can play for a win it
doesn't feel like I'm in a position to
play for a win here so okay I was
leading the tournament and he was doing
okay too but I think he thought this is
his chance to try to beat me and pass me
so he's playing for a win and I'm a
little bit low on the clock you know
that's why you know he had all the he
thought it was the right moment to take
a risk
Quincy 5 I've got to avoid going to end
game because in games I'm gonna be
slightly worse with zero chances to win
because he'll have the C file here and
plus I have to deal with this weakness I
need the Queen on the board to be able
to attack this weakness only three okay
so what should I do
don't necessarily trade Queens here so
here I played Queen e8 yes yeah I parry
Queen e8 but actually better move was
Queen f7 they came across my mind to be
honest well that's again according to
the computer after half the game when
you analyze this is a little bit better
move apparently because you can keep the
bishop here and rook comes in here
didn't really cross my mind I was I
wasn't gonna put my queen on the line of
the bishop you know so I proved pic we
need which is fine Queen before by my
opponent okay I don't want to play b6
because he's gonna go rock c7 so I go
rook d7 defending it this way now he
goes rook c3
and now how should I try to organize my
own attack by the way cannabis is doing
your idea here he's trying to get the
roots on a sea fire but he didn't sense
the moment it's dangerous to do this you
know because I have my own counter play
this is an example of a game when
opponent is not careful he is only
thinking about his ideas ignoring what
opponent is trying to do in creating a
contra play how should i try to generate
my own culture play here to try to even
get a win here absolutely
h5 with idea h4 rook FC Wando
he believes that rookie c7 is going to
be strong enough
by the way another idea I hid here was
queen g6 was a strong idea and the point
is let's say you go here rook f8 the
rook c7 you get into a trouble by this
Nick move it's actually a very strong
move because now it's actually just wins
yeah but without this it's not so clear
because my b7 is hanging in so this was
another good idea that I had but this
was my plan and you choose a plant you
stick with it you don't have to always
play the the computer best moves to win
a chess game you don't actually because
humans they don't play like a computer
so even if you play a third best move
forward based more of the computer as
long as you're doing something you're
improving the position you'll be fine so
I had a plants I was just gonna stick
with my plan here now he plays here and
now I realize I'm sort of not in time
here he's just a little bit faster when
it comes down to the Contra play and
this pawn on e6 is constantly hanging
it's constantly hanging you know it
cannot move my queen anywhere because I
had to keep protecting this pawn this is
one example why I was like didn't like
this yes check check check and you know
it's it's not good suddenly he's meeting
me big trouble so
I came with my queen yet because of the
rook c8 idea so what did I do here h4 h4
but what's the age for I think there was
some problem with this stage for yeah I
think Roxy 7 it's just less too slow
e to human Oh e - what's the plan let's
say he stays with the program
now this guy's hanging and then B three
rocks is seven yeah now you have to be
very careful let's Bishop on I kept
calculating I kept realizing that you
know my problem is this Bishop it's just
too active
so when opponent has an active piece
what do we do
exchange it so correct move is
absolutely Bishop c4 if he takes he
doesn't have much I mean this was the
line take take take take you're here
yes well the problem I have it's not
like I didn't want to move the rook I
don't have a useful move to play this
with and I ideally I want to put it on
an F file ideally but I can't that Quinn
is on the way and I can't play queen g6
because I had all these problems to deal
with so I say okay she's gonna go for it
I have about five minutes here left it
was time wise it wasn't looking good I
was getting a little bit worried time
pressure is looming you know and okay if
he takes it's just a draw probably but
is again very aggressively playing for a
win
Bishop f1 and he's that thing Bishop b5
and if I play a move like a six he goes
Roxy seven and he gets in and not so
good this is where I realize this is the
moment to go for it we have no time to
defend against the Bishop e5 threat we
have to go for the immediate counter
play and which move is gonna give the
counter play much better suggestion yes
h4 let's open up that King and here he
makes the mistake
so the key line here is Bishop e5 you
should have done this I take
so he has two ideas Bishop d7 one which
loses the game check
he takes check
look at that king despite the material
advantage she cannot escape the maiden
net yeah okay so I mean he has a check
here no problem no more checks
and he's in that net because of this
bishop now you realize how strong that
Bishop on f3 is especially when it's
supported by a pawn on e4 so that's one
variation so he has to take back here if
he doesn't want to lose and I think this
ends in a draw this line like many of
the line nice lines the interest usually
end in a draw so he takes Bishop d7 and
here it's very interesting moment here
if I play Bishop here which looks like
I'm just winning him right I'm actually
losing because check I cannot go to h5
rook c8 check so he has to go here and
looks like wait mate is there but he's
got an amazing defense here suddenly
amazing defense who can find it
it's so easy to miss this idea you get
to this position you you think in great
win for block and then this move comes
in it just turns the evaluation upside
down the Queen a five you just delayed
it right you just delayed the threat of
Queen each one
who can see that defensive resource here
huh
well I'm treating mate in mate now mate
so what would be the defense idea
concrete because you have to do
something about Queen h1 yes Roxy - see
- it does run away but very very brief
very briefly
a pichia beginner that bishop again he's
playing a huge role I had the rook okay
check-check
check-check
now the queen is on the wrong square
check that that only delays it no I mean
I just take with the rock and Neil you
had an idea but you came short calculate
Bishop f5 Queen takes f5
data
when you're under attack which pieces
are usually good to have around that can
guard a lot of squares Queen so you play
27 and now he has to go here I had go
here and exchanges the Queens okay but
don't worry we're not losing here we
just need to make the right decision
here and the right decision here is
Queen h3 threatening this way we see we
keep this under control
so Queen h3 goes rook c8 rook c8
Roxy 8 king h7 Queen h7 and Queen f8 23
King f1
in the screen g3 check and if he goes
here she actually loses the game
check mate so he has to go here and
unfortunately I cannot take now because
of queen f2 goes back so I have to
settle for the repertoire okay okay we
both didn't see all this dad well I felt
my attack is very close so I went for it
and he got you know probably really
worried about it he's like I gotta keep
my Bishop so he goes here rook c7
mistake now I calculated this and found
a way to turn the tables and get a
better position now now first things
first this is a problem that stroke
always hanging always things to worry
about okay even if you take he can take
so I figure get rid of this next thing
is when you do all this H 5 H 4 what is
the ultimate idea doing that of course
create weaknesses and now the weakness
is created in opponent's camp so now he
plays and here he he completely lost the
thread of the game and he was just
trying to move fast to get me into time
trouble which you don't do you don't
play on your opponent's clock you use
your time in accrue crucial moments like
this to make the right decision and he
played a bad move he should have taken
actually I don't have anything
immediately so I just go b6 he doesn't
have anything better than here just try
to do things I take take and I go rook
c8
sick sick Kim Jiwan
yeah it looks like sorry okay look takes
me to and looks like it's roughly cooled
by me it's better to be blocked and
white here obviously but I don't know if
there is a breakthrough plant okay so
that was the idea and he panicked here
he played a move h3 that that's a very
risky mo because if my queen ever lends
to f2 you know what's gonna happen here
game over so he was really worried about
this
HC now I found the idea here I spend the
remaining of my time and I was down a
minute but I found the idea and it was
over
there is nothing he could have done to
escaped escaped from the defeat black to
play who can find a winning move here by
the way there's actually a problem know
if it takes this is hanging
yeah this g7 this g7 is very important
pawning are very important to have it
guarded excellent move
bravo Bravo Queen is going to age six
that is the idea now okay he took on b7
that just loses immediately well let's
just look at the game first and then
we'll go to this so he took here
attacking my rook what do you do you
know Brooke is hanging Neil of course ok
fate yeah and now he played rook c8 and
after my next one he resigned because
he's just getting made it so let's
finish this and then we look at a
critical line what is the move that is
gonna make you resign here you probably
missed this move because Neil yes Queen
f5 remember what did I tell you when
this pawn is here what do you want to
put your Queen on f2 to mate and now
that's what I'm going to do it takes
what did he overlooked here and capture
back with the Queen he takes check and
now you choose the checkmate do you like
this or this one doesn't matter so he
resigned after queen fi because he's
getting mated and if he tries to
interpose this check check mate that's
called a wedge pawn when you have a
wedge pawn it's very strong to have that
when you're attacking him so the g3 pawn
is very very powerful very strong which
pawn
so the critical line is this actually
this rook c8 is just losing so that's
that's just a bad move so the critical
line here would have been the following
one
he takes what do I do here because it's
tricky you know he might he might escape
so what more do you play here to create
a threat better tix f1 takes
I know but I don't know he just takes
the Quinn that's the problem we don't
need to sacrifice more we just need to
find the right square for our piece
again you use the wedge pawn that pawn
wedge of course Queen h6 and that's it
actually with this Queen yeah yeah so
yeah Queen chicks win say so so the line
here is the screen b7 issues just bad so
the line here actually he should do this
without the Queen so you should take
plan is to connect six right now that he
made a bishop comes I go check and rook
a face so he's gonna go here Queen d2
and now
fate dirting take and check on h1
g5
correct
jeetu threating mate
he goes here but it looks like he's
holding it see what well if you Quinn he
takes and you're gonna be up upon but
it's not gonna be easy to win the
opposition Queen h2 quiet move and neat
move that wins the game and now you're
ready to play g1 check and pick up the
you know get a new queen exchange that's
a very strong idea Queen h2 and if the
King moves away then he's blocking the
rook and that's why it's wins yeah then
he gets made it or he loses the Queen
basically I get a new queen all right so
the critical part was actually the big
mistake for him was to play h3 that cost
him a game you can never allow I mean
unless there is the immediate mate yeah
you should try too late but otherwise
you have to take this pawn this pawn was
the big problem it was very strong on g3
constantly putting threats okay so
that's what you gotta try to remember
don't allow the opponent to have a wedge
pump for you you should try to have a
backbone and the which point is if
you're playing black if it's on a 3rd
rank if you're playing white on a 6th
rank that is called a wedge pawn very
strong to have a wedge pawn for for the
side who has it so here in this game you
saw how I use this wedge pawn to win the
game ok ok great thank you everybody for
coming to this class and see you next
time
you
[Music]